piers morgan has zero love for meghan
markle he has made that quite clear
but apparently he took his megan
obsession too far and you know what
the duchess has struck back sure did and
that may be why he's out of a job now
but pierce
is doubling down
i don't believe almost anything that
comes out of her mouth
so if i have to fall on my sword for
expressing an honestly held opinion
about that dire tribe of bilge in that
interview so be it
a defiant piers unwavering in the
anti-megan stance that led to his
departure from good morning britain
piers morgan is not here this morning
but shows go on
and so on we go but the big question did
megan take him down
multiple reports has surfaced she was
one of the 41 000 complaints lodged
against his on-air rant monday
were you having suicidal thoughts yes
this was very very clear i'm sorry i
don't believe a word she says megan
there are so many people who are afraid
to voice that they need help
megan's team reportedly filed the
complaint out of concern other people
with suicidal thoughts
could be shamed into the shadows itv
asked pierce to apologize on air
he refused then quit
a lot of people no i believe in freedom
of speech
i believe in the right to be allowed to
have an opinion
sharon osborne is one of the few
celebrities to have publicly voiced
support for morgan
and has faced some heat for it did i
agree
with what he said no everybody goes
if you support him then you must be
racist
because he's racist i'm not racist
neither appears racist while you're
standing by your friend
it appears that you give safe haven to
something that he has uttered that is
racist i i feel even like
uh i'm about to be put in the electric
chair because i have a friend
who many people think is a racist so
that makes me a racist
that's when the conversation this
morning on the talk escalating
i think we should stop this
don't try and cry because if anyone
should be crying it should be me
right now i'm talking to a woman who i
believe is my friend
and i don't want anybody here to
to watch this and say that we're
attacking you for being racist he did it
i think it's
too late i think that he's already sewn
pierre's wife journalist celia walden
agreed with her husband's stance saying
megan deserves an oscar for the
interview meanwhile many other stars
have shown piers
no mercy